all right to Tim Hogan question 8 are
the chemical properties of natural
tennis racquet strings better than
synthetic ones hmm that's interesting
that you ask me this because I used to
play tennis I was not bad and we got to
the finals a couple of times plate for
Sheffield the finals of the UAE and I
was probably the weak link because we
lost a couple of times in the final and
I really did like gut gut strings
because it was much sharper they're more
expensive and they didn't last very long
and I just didn't like the sort of
squash eNOS and the but I don't know
about modern the modern sort of sort of
strings because I got injured in 1981
and really haven't been able to play
properly since then I got injured
playing tennis I got a shoulder injury
and then I was going to come back weight
training that I got tennis elbow and
then c60 turned up and that really did
mess up my life for the last 25 years
because there's 25th anniversary you
know was the discovery was last week as
Google pointed out and so for me the
when I was playing the sharpness and the
and the sort of the real loss lack of
stretch ability was very important the
the frequency of king was higher and you
hit it whereas with the sort of plastic
and polymer strings but maybe those
problems been solved now I I should find
out actually I mean certainly I do have
a racket over there and it is a polymer
racket but
I'm not quite as good a player as I used
to be